[Music]
the rancor people have been hurting
camels here in Rajasthan for centuries
Raika tradition holds that Lord Shiva
created their caste specifically so they
could look after camels but times have
changed their traditional way of life is
now under threat mechanized farming has
long been able to do much of the work
that camels once did so their market
value has dropped sharply the last 30
years have seen the camel population in
Rajasthan shrink dramatically who ban
wala Rekha says his father used to have
twice as many camels as he does
traditions have been handed down for
generations they mean a lot to us but
how can we uphold our traditions when we
have no income and young people have to
leave for the cities to make a living my
children go to school that cost me a lot
every month if we can no longer make a
living with our camels how are we going
to survive in the cooler olufsen is an
ethnologist and veterinarian together
with hanwant singh ratoff she set up an
organization that helps camel herders
sustain their livelihood
it's an advocacy group for Ryker and
their camels and also raises awareness
that the animals play a crucial role
protecting the environment grazing helps
tree conservation in many ways a lot of
trees can only germinate with the help
of reminisce that you there cut it's a
natural cycle humans camels the bio
tones and the production of quality
foodstuffs
retinols Mittal soy
camels are the only animals that eat
Indian globe thistle these short spiky
plants are a nightmare for farmers
without the camels the plant would
proliferate all over the fields and
choke the crops camels graze by breaking
off a few branches chewing a few leaves
and moving on
it's a grazing practice that encourages
regeneration the camels need large
browsing areas and can cover 10
kilometres a day but changes to
agriculture mean that pasture land is in
short supply hanwant singh rata has been
working with camel herders for nearly
three decades in the past angie kudani
was a thriving village locals owned some
three thousand camels between them now
many locals have since switched to
buffalo herding it's more profitable
they also don't want a very bad
condition of the cameras and bad
situation if you like it next the next
five years you can't see any camels in
on the road or anywhere because nobody
wants
if camels disappear from the roads of
Rajasthan traditional Reika culture
could also disappear and with it their
expertise in agro pastoral herding
practices once a year bull calves are
sold at camel markets for centuries this
has been rikers main source of income
they keep the cows for breeding
camel milk is highly nutritious and a
staple of the Reika diet they used to
say selling camel milk is like selling
your children but that's changing too
now every morning ban walla raker takes
camel milk to a dairy founded three
years ago by other cooler hollow sons
NGO i was about to give up I'd sold my
camels then the organization began
selling camel milk so I got my herd back
now I can feed my family with what I am
selling camel milk if the organization
stopped selling milk tomorrow I'd have
to sell the herd again last year he even
bought more camels doubling his herds
milk production the dairy has also
turned around tell Aram Rika's fortunes
when he was a boy his family sent him to
the city to earn a living he spent 15
years tiling and restaurants hotels and
tea shops I worked in the city for years
and for less money than I'm earning here
I started in the dairy two months ago I
know a lot about camel milk I'm very
happy working here I hope the dairy
continues to do well looking at elegant
doggy I'm here to do camels have a very
diet eating 36 different types of plants
known for their medicinal properties so
their milk is believed to have many
health benefits
but for now the camel charisma micro
dairy still isn't selling as much as it
could it's operating at just a third of
its capacity
it needs more buyers at the moment we
have only about six families supplying
us but there's a huge amount of interest
we get calls every day from like asking
if we can buy their milk so it's a big
concern we've seen that Reika who can
earn a living selling their milk are
able to keep their camels surplus milk
has turned into soap a product that
sells well another step towards ensuring
the Ryker and income further products
that have been developed include
textiles made from camel hair this paper
is made from camel dung but the biggest
challenge is finding customers tourists
sometimes visit and sample the local
camel milk zocalo hollofson takes the
opportunity to raise awareness of hiker
culture and the threat it faces after
Labine even avoid a global level the UN
has recognized the importance of
pneumatic agar pastoralism so we're
moving in the right direction but the
question is can we help before time runs
out to preserve their herds the right
can need to make a living 30 years ago
there were 1 million camels in Rajasthan
today it's just a fifth that nearly all
the herders are now old if they aren't
joined by a younger generation this
traditional way of life will soon be
lost
you